Oh God
not yet but I will be we all will be
except for you you'll be dead good no
wait look I don't know what's going on
here but you won't kill me get wise me
remember from Spock Bob Bob dr. claw
nice
we as sisters are born again at least
yet the blood of a virgin elder we
restore our high winds and start anew
pure as a wholesome hey I'm not a virgin
I'm a virgin okay all right you know
what I see where the confusion might
have come from but that is old news
sister okay I am a sexpert - no I do sex
I do
Oh either way this is really sad the
power of grace goes we are sergeant once
more she was very sexually progressive -
what a
Oh
Oh what is that
no what is that Oh No please you know
what I did it his name was Brent and we
did it in a t-shirt so specific and
pathetic they almost want to believe her
is the biggest aesthetic bullies meet
nylons serpents live can't free her from
the hands of God I hope you didn't like
living by Billy or hi Billy gene what
that was a rhyme and a badass intro get
back Hulk
stay away from my thank you Jim
hero you can have her oh that was easy
like Billy Cece come and get her I am hi
nice to meet you oh that damn team she's
pregnant don't know I'm not bitch johar
bitch you fat bitch yeah I think I'm
gonna take off my chest is like kind of
cramping so I don't leave without Billy
well you can always go with her
new case of a TV that's why you don't
see fun but they still wanna be